may have been addicted to doing the
larger stunts that really could take me
out I know I can never get in with
another bull again but I physically miss
it if that makes sense I get it you're
done risking your life and thank God
because I never wanted to see you at the
bowl in the first place I definitely
never want to see you with another bull
again let me put it out there that it
was on the third movie I showed up and I
said if it's a risk of paralysis or
death I'm not doing it but if there's
not that risk then I'm in I just showed
up at the same roles on jackass forever
and one weekend I called it that the
treadmill stunt was a real problem for
the spine and the brain and consciously
deliberately threw my rules out the
window for that you did yeah so I
understand what you're saying when you
say that you miss doing the physical
stunts because here I knew not to do
that